we have all now accepted that simple and
Navi won't be hoisting csgo's final
major trophy but this wasn't just your
regular premature exit from a tournament
because of his actions this may have
been an outcome months in the making and
it's got a lot of people wondering did
simple's Ego get the better of him once
again
[Music]
the Paris major has already had a ton of
upsets from teams failing to even
qualify to favorites getting sent home
early and at the top of that list of
what the moments is what happened to
Navi in case you missed it Navi was sent
to the airport by phase after a heated
elimination match but that wasn't the
shocking part it was the absolute
clapping they took from Monty that
landed them there in the first place and
this wasn't just your standard CS go
upset this was an entire anime Arc
involving the most prolific player in
the history of Cs go a scoring fan and
may have been caused by simples Infamous
toxicity listen this goes deep so
let's drop in okay if you're thinking
who the hell is Monty that's a fair
reaction because they're a relatively
unknown CIS roster minus for two
somewhat familiar faces sdy and war02k
but to get the full picture we need to
first take a step back when I mentioned
simples documented toxicity I'm not just
pulling it out of my ass it's been well
known for a long time that that the
Ukrainian Superstar can be a bit
difficult to work with
channels
but we will win it who the want to
win we can win on another map five we
should play second Bob second Bob cash
oh my God in the Quest for greatness
simple often clashed with his teammates
on basically every roster but in 2021 it
seemed like things had finally changed
with boomich at the helm simple had
found his golden Squad and it led to the
goat finally getting his major
bit 10 seconds
he just has to watch that clock tick
down
[Applause]
however shortly after that historic win
something else caused a change in simple
the invasion of Ukraine flipped many
parts of the world upside down and even
affected those within the Cs go
community and in its wake simple became
a different type of player for the first
time ever he was more than just a
superstar he was an example of humanity
within Esports and became a figure that
everyone could be proud of us
need to show example on this tournament
for whole world we need to stay together
as a unit with our fans with our friends
with everyone who is gonna watch this
tournament
and we all need to stay humans first but
while simple was making these massive
character developments things that the
navi Camp would become uncertain and
that's where we get to sdy after
boomich's extremely public benching in
May of 2022 Navi found a temporary
replacement in sdy it wasn't a perfect
fix given the fact that sdy wasn't an
igl like boomich but after another
massive win at blast spring finals the
new edition seemed to be working out
just fine unfortunately that success
didn't last very long results quickly
turned sour and sdy was dropped bringing
17 year old npl in and although there
was an argument to be made about sdy's
performance many CS go fans felt uneasy
about the team's treatment of him on
several occasions simple visibly and
verbally accosted sdy for mistakes he
made in the server this event to look
quite Sharp
it was a it was a good move right there
from now simple being a bit toxic
towards a teammate is obviously nothing
new but to make matters worse Navy's
coach made comments towards sdy after
his departure that felt just unnecessary
specifically suggesting that sdy was
past his Prime and likely wouldn't
develop any further all of this can be
taken out of context which is something
that sdy sort of echoed on top of that
there are even some reports that claim
simple wanted the two to continue
playing together what isn't up to
interpretation is the situation with
war02k last year at the kinguin Legends
tournament which is classified as a show
match by the way the two ukrainians 402k
and simple played on the same team
together in the grand finals and to say
things got ugly would be an
understatement shortly after the loss in
the grand finals warro would tweet out a
jab at simple saying this it's a shame
to realize that the player you love most
except for crying and telling someone
something did nothing himself now you
might be wondering what would cause to
say such a thing towards one of his
idols
well
after warro's initial tweet the two
would bicker back and forth about
communication before waro dropped one of
the most anime ass lines I've ever seen
in the history of Esports beefs take
away your ego because the time will come
when I destroy you in tournaments
hilarious right well now let's fast
forward over six months later to the
Paris major sdy and waro's new team
Monty qualified for the tournament and
would go on to meet Navi in round four
of the legend stage winner moved on and
loser went to elimination to make things
even spicier this beef wasn't some
ancient history everyone remembered what
had happened between these two teams and
plenty of comments were made leading up
to the match right now there has been a
little bit of uh you know a spice
between worldsuke and simple is that
affecting you guys outside of the game
I think voro is a guy who is under
pressure performing better than normally
so everything will be good no problem
and guess what folks it all came full
circle because sdy and 402k popped the
off decimating Navi on their own
map pick 16 to 2. the Monty securing top
eight one frag away can for offended yes
he can that is beautiful the storyline
of that one take away your ego because
the time will come when I will destroy
you in tournaments and to make it all
even better after the unbelievable
outcome blast production knew exactly
who the cameras should follow this loss
of course sent Navi into a Do or Die
match against phase where simple and
Company were dealt a crushing defeat in
overtime now simple getting knocked out
of the final major is definitely one
thing but the context surrounding the
entire match with Monty and simple's own
dismal performances really Lee sent the
community over the edge simple might
just be the best player of all time but
no one was going to let him off the hook
for this one on a more serious note some
were questioning if this loss
highlighted an even bigger issue the
potential return of a toxic simple when
it comes to the 402k situation I
honestly think it's a close case simple
got owned he was an Warwick
threw down the gauntlet and then blast
them out of the water all of this added
Twitter talk about ego and hubris is
just flavor but if we really wanted to
read into it this is just yet another
case of simple's toxic treatment of
other players I mean on top of 402k and
sdy we already know that simple has
publicly criticized MPL you know that 17
year old him and Navi are supposed to be
developing listen we can all go on and
on about what a Winner's mentality
really is or what certain attributes
other great players have that simple
lacks but at the end of the day we're
not him or any of his past or present
teammates so we'll never really know
what actually is going down what I do
know is that simple's time in CS go is
almost at an end Counter-Strike 2 is
going to be a fresh start for a lot of
people and for simple he has an
important choice to make once his
individual skill starts to wane a bit
because just like everyone else it
eventually will what type of player does
simple want to be one that leads and
mentors or one that's still just toxic
and Petty
I mean I think he definitely has one I
hope people don't come for me for this
I'm just stating the obvious you know
I'm not I'm not throwing any punches I'm
just putting it out there it's all
hypotheticals you sure you look at you
know Michael Jordan LeBron Sydney Crosby
like all these players are chippy and
they
you know they do every little thing to
try and get an edge and that's how you
become the best that's how you be the
best but I think like what I'm trying to
get to is like at the end of your career
or towards the end of your career like
there's a choice to make of like what
you want to be remembered for and
honestly it's a video game so it
doesn't really matter but I mean I like
simple when he's smiling